brought to you by Final Fantasy 15
available on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
November 29th hey guys the 23rd of
November today my name's Justin here the
things I've been making waves in gaming
xbox boss Phil Spencer is that that he'd
love to see Microsoft's relationship
with Nintendo lead to future
partnerships the to publishers recently
works together to bring minecraft to we
year Spencer told of gamers Nintendo has
the strongest first party of anybody
there just fantastic and the memories
that they've instilled in so many of us
who played their games and had those
delightful experiences having those on
Xbox would be great I would love to see
Mario on Xbox he added I know I get
questions all the time on would I like
to see fan Joe in Super Smash Brothers
and I'm like yes I would do that in a
second if we ever had the chance to work
with them in the future I would
absolutely do it next up Mass Effect
fans may want to tune in carefully for
this one as the deluxe editions for Mass
Effect Andromeda have been detailed
everyone who pre-orders the game will
receive the deep space explorer armor a
multiplayer booster pack containing 5 50
% XP boosters and a bonus skin for your
ship the Nomad the $70 deluxe edition
also includes a number of extra armor
sets a weapon sets a pet space monkey to
tell you around the galaxy the official
soundtrack and the multiplayer deluxe
launch pack containing a bunch of gear
and a weaponry for you to use on co-op
missions if you have a little more cash
you want to throw Bioware's way at the
$100 super deluxe edition comes with all
of that +1 multiplayer super deluxe
booster pack every week for 20 weeks
finally a Gamestop earnings call may
have clued us into more details about
Nintendo's switch the airport reins said
the Nintendo switch which I played at a
Nintendo a few weeks ago we believe
could be another game-changer that will
expand the audience for gaming friends
also noted that early metrics showed
game star powerup Rewards members are
interested in the system and 27% of
members aware of the console intends to
buy one that might not seem like a
massive amount but it's a pretty similar
metrics to what Xbox one purchase intent
was like
at a similar point in time rains also
suggested that the Nintendo switch may
have had some kind of motion controls as
he said a movement related game is more
fun for kids you know taking those Joey
Kahn controllers off and then the master
controller you can really do a lot of
interesting things with that in game
play I think it has tremendous potential
as a game changer be sure to leave me
your thoughts on today's stories down in
that comment box head to GameSpot for
all sorts of Black Friday deals and
discounts in us see you again tomorrow